okay well this is it the end of the
journey the final
class so we've done a lot this year
right last semester we did the great
books The Iliad The Odyssey the Bible
the Republic Divine
Comedy this semester we did how SC the
world is right the world is
hopeless uh we're all going to
die and and um in this final class I
want this class to be about
Hope and I want to show
you um the
future and the argument I want to leave
leave you with uh the thing that I want
you that I want you to remember is that
um remember Dante in Divine Comedy said
that the
future is not what happens to you
it's not something that you wait for the
future is what you
imagine and fight for the future is what
you make
happen there is a God but God gave us
the ability to imagine and the capacity
to
love and it's these two things that will
guide us and enable us to Build a Better
World okay so that's a message M I want
to give to you today the future is what
we
imagine not what not what we have to put
up with so if we don't like the future
if we don't like the way we live our
lives then we can change that with our
imagination and today I want to show you
how so just to summarize what we did
this
semester um together we analyzed the
world and we made certain predictions
about the world right for example that
Trump will be elected again in
November and that he will declare war on
Iran and this war in Iran will be a
disaster for the United States and it
will mean the end of the American Empire
and it would lead to a multi-polar world
which will mean endless war and the
deaths
of millions and billions of of people
and because of climate change our world
will eventually collapse at some point
okay so this is an extremely hopeless an
extremely Bleak and dark picture of the
world but remember where there is
Darkness there can also be light so in
this final class I want to show
you some hope and some light okay so
this is what we call Psycho
history and psycho history is the idea
that the future can be predicted and if
it can be predicted then it can be
controlled and harnessed for the
betterment of humanity okay so where
does this idea come from psycho history
in in the 1950s there was an American
science fiction writer named Isaac
Asimov and and he's
probably the most famous science fiction
writer okay if you happen to read
science fiction he's really famous and
he wrote A series called
Foundation um and I think there's a TV
series now based on Foundation books
it's terrible but uh you can have a look
at it and in the foundation books he
introduces the idea of psycho
history and so this book is set in the
future like a million years from now
where there is a Galactic
Empire um so Humanity has colonized the
entire Milky Way There are billions of
planets and there's an Empire that
brings peace to this uh to to this Milky
Way but with all Empires it has to
collapse and this will lead to 30,000
years of war violence
uh
barbarity um and the foundation proposes
a new science called psycho history
which is to mathematically map out human
behavior over the course of a million
years if you do that what you discover
is that there are certain patterns to
Human
Society okay and if that's the case then
you can predict the future if you can do
that then you can manipulate the course
of events to make a better future okay
so this this is what they called psycho
history and it's a science science
fiction concept and a lot of people have
been trying to make it into reality okay
so there's this very um uh prominent
historian his name is
Peter uh
turkin and he's one of the founders of
something called Cleo
Dynamics okay and Cleo uh is the goddess
of History Dynamics just means movement
okay so basically Cleo Dynamics is
trying to figure out the mathematical
movement of History he's trying to
create um history as a mathematical
model and when he did that there's
certain interesting Trends and patterns
that he discovered okay and one idea
that he that he discovered is something
called
the over
production of the
elites okay over production of the elite
and this concept explains why societies
collapse now traditionally we've
understood the collapse of societies as
as having to do with maybe like too much
debt or too much inequality or maybe
climate change or War right what Peter
turkin points out and it's a really
interesting idea is the reason why
Societies collaps in the end is you have
too many Elites all right so let me
explain the concept okay
so um Society has many Elites right you
have people like Jack ma right you have
people like Jo Jae right movie
stars uh you have famous milit
generals
okay um so over time Elites become more
and more numerous right number of
wealthy
people go up the number of famous people
go up uh the number of um entrepreneurs
go up
okay the problem though is they all want
power right now wealth and fame are all
infinite
resources right but Power will always be
a finite resource in fact it's what it's
what we call a zero sum game so for
example in this classroom there can only
be one
teacher right if we're all teachers
there's no
teacher so in society there can only be
a few powerful people if everyone has a
power no one has any power okay so what
happens over time is that all these
people who believe they should have
power struggle for power and because
there too many of them this internal
struggle of the elites ultimately leads
to social
collapse okay so the most famous example
is in China in Imperial China where you
had the C system
right people taking the uh Imperial
examinations to become official problem
is you have too many candidates not
enough positions right and guess who
ultimately gets upset with society and
leads revolutions it's the kuu
candidates who did not become
officials and so they become angry and
they lead revolutions to overthrow the
society right so the most classic
example of the um failed could candidate
is
hongran do you guys know who he is the
leader of the typing Rebellion right why
did he be why did he become a Christian
why did he lead the Rebellion because he
failed to C you okay so that's the idea
of the over production of the elite and
he discovered this principle using
mathematically modeling of History okay
he just compared different societies and
um
um try to figure out why they collapsed
okay and what he discovered is well it's
because um of the internal struggle
among the different Elite groups okay
and that's why the Roman Empire collaps
as well okay does that make sense okay
what I'm proposing to you is that we can
actually go a step further than what
Peter turkin is doing because we have
something called now called
AI okay artificial artificial intellig
and we can harness the power of AI to
create real cycle history which is the
ability to not just analyze the past but
to predict the
future okay all right so let's first
figure out what AI is okay so first I
want us to understand what artificial
intelligence
is
because um most of you think you know
but you don't actually know okay so what
is AI all right the AI the technical
term is
supervised
machine
learning okay that's the technical term
AI is the popular term but supervised
machine learning is the technical and
correct term have you guys heard of this
term supervised machine learning yes or
no have you have any of you taken
computer
science okay this is called supervis
machine learning okay so so what is this
okay
so um in computer programming you're
taught to write the algorithm
right and then the input you put in
information it gives you the
output okay and this is traditionally
how computers work you write the
algorithm the computer program you put
in information and then there's an
output right for example the algorithm
could be like uh a plus b okay so you
put in two numbers two two you get a
four okay that's how computers work
right now supervised machine learning is
that I will turn the output into the
input okay and the reason why I want to
do that is that as a human
being I
myself uh may not be able to write the
best
algorithm so I want the
computer to refine the algorithm for me
to optimize it using um the output okay
does that make sense all right so let's
talk about a very specific
example all
right um so let's look at
facial recognition technology
right you go to the airport and you scan
and they know who you are right you go
to a supermarket you scan your phase and
you pay right you're like wait how does
that work
okay so how this works is that there's a
database okay about one billion people
like everyone in China and now what I
need to do is figure out how to
differentiate the faces of everyone in
China in this database okay does that
make sense so what I do is for the phase
I create a mathematical model based on
topology okay does that make sense
topology so I I turn everyone's face
into a mathematical model okay which
looks like something like this
okay and you're like I don't know what
this is okay it's you don't need to know
what this is this is like super pop kit
okay but all you need to know is that
within this model there are different
equations okay so for
example it this model is trying to
analyze the distance between your eyes
okay and and how big your nose
is all right does that make sense all
right um and so once I create this
mathemtical
model I am now able to differentiate
everyone in China does that make sense
okay in fact this math this mathem modle
is so precise that I can only look at
your eyes and I know who you
are okay because what I'm trying to do
is match what your model with the with a
model in the database all right but what
what's important to remember is that if
you're not in this
database you can't be recognized okay do
you understand all right now what I will
show you is how this model is created so
what happens is this all right what I do
is I teach the computer how to create
this database so I've have input I've
output and then what I do is I create a
working thesis or a working theory of
what this model should look like okay
does that make sense all right so it
could be like this
all
right and then what I do is I put
faces okay and the output should match
what's in the
database and if the model returns
something that's different and I tell
them this is wrong and what the computer
then does is we find this model until it
becomes this does that make sense okay
so what this what all AI is is infinite
iteration
okay does that make
sense all right okay
so the problem with AI is I need to be
able to solve three things and if I can
solve three things then I can create an
AI okay the first thing is that I
need
um clear metrics okay or clear Al
puts okay doesn't make sense I need
outputs that I can I can Define as a
methal
model okay so for
example
um if I'm an airline I'm use I'm going
to use AI to maximize the amount of
money I make on a flight right okay
that's my output how much money can I
make out of a flight I want to have the
maximum amount of profit okay that's the
first thing I need to solve second thing
I need to solve then is data okay for
input but the thing about data is that
it has to be
clean okay does that make sense it has
to be a clean data okay so for example
if I want to teach this AI to recognize
different
animals I need to give it
different um
data sets of different animals okay does
that make sense I need to label my
data but I can't tell I can't make an AI
That's like this is the best ice cream
in the world and the reason why is I
can't find data on the best ice cream
you understand because ice cream is the
best ice cream is
subjective so I cannot turn that into a
data set okay does that make sense Okay
the third thing I need to do
is create a
working algorithm
structure do you understand okay
computers can only refine and
optimize the algorithm structure it
cannot create it by
itself okay so if I'm able to do all
three
things then I'm able to use AI to
optimize
um what I wanted to optimize okay all
right any questions so far before I move
on okay so what this means is that there
are certain problems that I can solve
using Ai and there are certain problems
I cannot solve using AI okay so um what
are easy problems that AI can solve
right well for example facial recog
facial recognition technology okay also
translation software right I can create
an optimal translation software also Rec
recommendation engines right so if you
watch a movie on Netflix it's recommends
in another movie
right
okay now let me ask you this
question can I ever solve self-driving
cars can I ever solve S soft selfing
driving cars self-driving cars can cars
drive by them by
themselves yes or
no why why you ask
Sally okay the answer is no why is the
answer
no okay the answer to no
is whatever I do okay I cannot solve
something call the The Edge
case the edge case is if the car is on
the
road what could happen that would screw
up my AI system you guys know why can't
self-driving cars be
solved why can't we have self driving
cars in in on the
roads what what what's a what's the edge
case or the thing that I can never
solve what is it
excuse
me yeah and what is not
planned
H they can plan for traffic what canot
what what can they not not plan
for and this is why we'll never have
suff driving
cars they can plan for accidents what
what can they not plan
for easily planned for traffic rules
for okay guys The Edge case with self-d
cars is if I as a human being
intentionally want to crash into that
car do you
understand does that make sense to you
guys every other situation I can plan
for but in a situation where I'm the
human being and I don't like sub driving
cars because I'm a taxi driver and it's
stealing my job right it's stealing my
my life likelihood and I want to crash
in that car there's no way for that AI
to avoid the accident does that make
sense
okay you we listen
listen AI is a scam okay it does not
exist what exists is supervised machine
learning okay what is supervised machine
learning what I just told you okay
that's it that's the extent of our
technology it can it does not have
self-awareness it can only do what the
algorithm tells it to do and there's no
way you can design an algorithm that
plans for and prevents a human being who
who who intentionally wants to crash
into you okay does that make sense all
right so AI in other words is an
extremely limited
tool okay so you think about actual
application of of AI it's it's very Li
lied you also look at self-driving cars
now there are cars that have
self-driving
features but they are not 100%
self-driving okay does that make sense
in fact they tell you don't don't rely
on the autopilot okay it's there to help
you but don't sleep in the car okay
right
because um they don't have an a system
in place to prevent people from crashing
into them okay does that make sense all
right so now that we know what AI is
let's talk about how we can use AI to
predict the future
okay okay all right so basically what
you need to
do is three things right you need to be
clear about the output you need to have
clean data and you need to have a
working algorithm okay does that make
sense and so that's what I've been doing
this
semester okay so for example remember
what we remember my
predictions um the issue of
Lobby Saudi
Arabia and the American Empire uh basic
basically the need to prot protect the
petrol dollar will force America to go
to war with Iran okay these are the push
factors the problem is that there are no
fact there no Force to counteract this
okay so for example the
military will be for this because they
have shotgun all and they're are very
confident they can win this war okay
okay Iran itself wants this war because
it wants revenge against
America okay and then the president of
the United States will be Donald Trump
he wants this war in order to cement his
position as president
okay and so because of this we can
predict that there'll be a war in Iran
doesn't make
sense okay
now given this prediction what we can
then do is use mathematical modeling and
statistics to turn this into an an AI
model okay does that make
sense okay now we have the AI
model now that we have the AI model what
we need to do now is to refin it and the
way we refined It Is by going back in
history and looking at every single war
that started okay doesn't make sense and
so you take this model and you look at
the different Wars okay so for example
the 415 BCE uh invasion of Sicily by
Athens uh you look at 1941 operation
Barbarosa okay you have basically
hundreds of wars
that you can look at and then you take
this model and then you test it using
each of these wars and what will happen
is that the model will begin to refine
itself okay does that make sense so it
BEC more and more
refined okay but then that's one model
for what causes
War I also said that um Trump will
become president
right well then that's another model
that you can use and once you start put
up putting all these models
together what eventually happens over
time is you develop psycho
history
okay does this make sense guys all right
so now the question then is
is okay how would this ai ai model work
or what are s of the
ideas behind this model okay so we talk
about Game Theory analysis A
Lot all right the idea of Game Theory
analysis is that okay guys there's
really no good and evil okay there are
different players in a game and they're
all self-interested they all want to win
this game so they're going to develop
strategies that optimize their ability
to win this game
okay so you can use Game Theory analysis
but then you can also develop new
ideas that would help you uh better
understand how the world works okay so
um let's talk let's talk about certain
ideas that have come up in this course
all right so one thing I want to talk
about is this week's European
elections have you guys seen the
news uh the elections to the European
Parliament right and the results are
pretty shocking
because um it signals a clear shift to
the right
so for example
um uh Mary Le Pen's party in France
picked up a lot of
votes uh the afd the alternative for
Germany in Germany which is considered a
right-wing organization almost um Neil
Nazi has picked up a lot of votes as
well the results were so dramatic that
um Emanuel macron the president of
France has called for an early election
and it's possible in 3 months Time Mary
leen's party will run and govern France
okay so how do we
explain this shift to the
right and I want to explain three
reasons okay the first reason
is
anti-migration okay so uh for the last
10 20 years there have been a lot of
immigrants to Europe from Libya from
Syria from Iraq Afghanistan Sudan
Somalia okay these are mainly
Muslim uh people who threaten the
Christian uh social fabric of Europe
okay and now Europeans are rebelling or
revolting against that second thing that
they don't like about Europe so far it's
the idea of
federalism okay or they can they can say
bureaucratism but it's the idea that a
foreign power
Brussels mandates rules that they must
follow so they think it's very
anti-democratic
okay um and the third thing that they
Rebellion against is the idea of pan
europeanism
what the people of Europe are saying is
there's no European identity guys
there's a German identity there's a
French identity Italian Spanish
Portuguese but there's no European
identity they're rebelling against the
entire project of the EU in fact I would
bet that in about five years time the
entire
EU would be dead
okay okay why are they why are they
opposed to uh pen uh
europeanism because
ultimately they
believe that it's about
destroying local identity it's about
destroying local community it's about
destroying my relationship with my
neighbors and my friends and my
relatives okay and my family does that
make sense okay it's imposing a foreign
identity on me
and um
proponents of of the European Union
believe would argue that no this is just
a
secular
liberal
um idea okay the entire idea of the EU
EU is that for hundred of years
thousands of year years Europe has been
at War why has Europe been at War
tribalism right religion so the entire
project of the EU is to get rid of the
factors that lead to war local identity
nationalism religion right and what the
European voters are saying to the EU is
um sorry we don't want secular
liberalism because we want to be human
okay what we strive for is not a
abstract liberal idea we strive for
structure
meaning and purpose in our
lives okay what we really strive for is
a capacity to love create and learn okay
and
grow does that make sense that's what we
are fundamentally as human
beings and when you ask me to obey an
abstract foreign
entity that is very far from me then you
are limiting or destroying the structure
meaning and purpose in my
life okay and so that's what's going on
not just in Europe but throughout the
world you think about brexit right you
think think about the election of Donald
Trump right all these things has to do
with this
fundamental human urge to have structure
meaning and purpose in our lives okay
have
agency okay does that make sense guys
all right any questions so
far yeah Eric
okay so Eric asked okay what is the
source of all this
and what Dante and Homer would say is
the human heart
okay the human
heart this is just who we
are and if we cannot fulfill our human
heart we will Rebel we will destroy we
will want to
kill okay and so in other
words one idea in this AI model is that
there is a
fundamental underlying structure to
Human Society okay if Society conforms
to the structure of the human heart this
this Society will prosper for example
Athens right the ancient Greeks that
Society prospered the word we use was
udonia
right okay but if a society
represses the human heart then
ultimately the society will have to
collapse at some
point
okay so that's another principle that we
can use when developing this AI
model the last idea that we can use um
in developing this AI model is the idea
of sity okay
sity and the idea of cinity is as a
society how willing are
people um how how willing are people in
following the rules it does that make
sense so when you drive the car do
people actually follow traffic rules
when you're in the subway do people
actually give up their seats for the
elderly for children for pregnant women
okay when you go to the park do people
actually pick up garbage and throw it in
the the garbage bin okay sity tells us
that that there's uh cohesion and Trust
in society that Society is
resilient
okay and that Society can grow okay or
learn from its
mistakes okay so societies that are that
have high sity will do better in the
long term in societies with low cinity
and so societies with high secrity would
include Japan and Germany right and
socities with low secrity would
include India and Brazil uh and China
okay does that make sense all right
so these are all of the ideas that we
we've developed this semester or in this
year that there's an underlying truth
and meaning to human
society and if we Embrace these truths
then Society will prosper but if we try
to deny these truths then eventually
Society will have to collapse and we
have to start over again okay does that
make sense any any questions so
far yeah Seline
excuse
me okay that's a great question okay um
so one thing that was not supposed to
happen um is the idea of mass
Society okay Mass Society you can say
that mass Society is a
complete um
what's the word I'm looking for
deviation from human history okay we're
not supposed to have we're not supposed
to have mass society and mass Society is
completed completely an accident a
historical accident but when you have
mass Society what happens is that you
need an
elite
okay you need an elite but guess what
guys uh the elite the people in charge
they're not better than you and me okay
do you
understand um we we in this
classroom could we could swap for the
leadership of the world right and guys
nothing would change you
understand right so you have mass
society and therefore you have to have
an artificial Elite because you need
people in control and because they're in
control they need to now Main maintain
the illusion of their
power okay they need they need to create
fictions for example maybe well I'm I
went to Yale or Harvard and therefore I
should be at the top or maybe have a
higher IQ than you do or maybe you know
my dad or my great great great great
grandfather was King okay they had to
create these fictions now what happens
over time is that these fictions fall
apart because they're not that confident
okay and the most recent example is you
look at the Global Management of the
economy and you look at the Global
Management of like covid okay you look
at the Global Management of War it's
pretty
incompetent and so people sort of wake
up and like wait a minute these guys
don't really know what they're doing
okay and now so now the elite is now
forced to suppress us okay that's a lie
they we have to use Force to to make us
obedient okay and that's what what's
happening today and so this repression
can go on for a long time but to control
us they must repress the human heart
okay because it's in the human heart to
want to
question to be curious
to um grow okay and if you think like
the people in charge don't know what
they're doing then you're sort of
compelled to challenge
them and so what they have to do is
suppress the human heart and they do
that by trying to get you to focus on
buying things rather than thinking okay
does does that make sense okay all right
any more
questions yes yes
Alie yes
yeah it has to turn it into a
mathematical model okay you understand
it h the human heart has to become like
a model like facial recognition model
okay does that make
sense okay so um Sally's question is
isn't it true that we're all individual
and unique and isn't it true that over
time we change okay and that's that's
great point but what Homer and Dante
would say that no no no no at the
fundamental level okay we all have the
same
desires we're motivated by the same
needs okay there's no one in this world
that does not want structure meaning and
purpose now the way you want to achieve
this may be different okay but that's
your underlying
motivation and there's no person in this
world that does not seek to have to to
to achieve these three things like love
create and grow as people okay that's
when you achieve full happiness as a
person when you feel that you're married
to someone you love and you have
children when you're doing a job that is
creative and when you're constantly
learning learning every day and growing
every day okay when you achieve that
these three things what do we call
this when you achieve all three things
what do we call
this udonia right this is udonia this is
what the Greeks meant by a happy and
self-fulfilled life it does that make
sense okay so there may be
differences in uh needs and motivation
but the fundamental at the fundamental
level we're all human beings and we're
all driven by the same fundamental needs
okay does that make sense
okay
yeah
yes okay so Sally asked the question
like how do you con construct this um AI
okay and so for this AI to be valid okay
let me explain how we would actually
Implement
okay so for first of all you need at
least 50 to 100
years to actually create this AI okay
and the reason why is that for this AI
to be valid you constantly need be you
need to be testing it okay so what I've
been doing this class is basically doing
a self AI right where I have an anacal
model and I have a prediction but guess
what guys we won't know if my
predictions are fully
correct uh until like 50 years from now
is that correct okay therefore I can't
validate my analysis until until 50
years from now okay does that make sense
okay and you need to be constantly doing
this where you have to be constantly
making these predictions and seeing if
they're correct or not if they're not
correct what you have to do is go and
change um these predictions okay uh and
an analysis okay does that make sense
then what you have to do is you
basically have to and and this is
actually what's the most time consuming
is you have to rewrite
history okay do you understand because
most of history is actually not correct
okay so what you have to do is you have
to take this model and look back at
history and says according to AI model
what actually happened uh in the pisan
war what actually happened in World War
I what actually
happened uh during the tong Dynasty okay
so you basically have to challenge the
entire discipline of history and
reconstruct a new history that you think
is more Fally correct based on this
AI okay so you have to do be doing the
these two things at
once okay making these predictions and
seeing that you're correct but also
going back to throughout history and
seeing how history can be revamped or
changed so it's so that it's more
accurate okay does that make sense okay
that's a project but now but now but
then there's the technology because you
actually need mathematicians and
computer programmers and historians to
collaborate together to build this AI
right
okay so I can tell you
the how I would analyze the issue but
then a mathematician has to turn this
into a mathematical equation or a model
okay because because computers only
recognize like data and and numbers okay
they don't they recognize ideas I can't
talk to a computer I have to give a
computer like a number or a equation or
a model okay for it to calculate
on okay do does that make
sense all right so it's not an easy
project okay but the argument is
that if this project actually works it
would change the fate of humanity
forever because if there's one thing
that you notice in this class it's like
we tend to repeat the same mistakes
right the question is like why do we do
that it's because the history that we
have have is complete it just
is it's not true it can't be
true
okay there's things that we believe
which if you just think about it can't
be
true okay and we did that like last
semester when we talked about the rights
of Christianity right you're tell me
that this illiterate guy named Jesus was
able to spread Christianity all by
himself after he died I don't believe
that okay I think a much easier
explanation is that it became coopted by
the Roman Empire in order to control the
Empire
right but if you were talk to a
historian they would say you're just
wrong okay so not only are you trying to
predict the future but you're trying to
also correct the past which is I think
an even more difficult
job right any more questions yeah Eric
excuse me oh so Eric asked a great
question will this Cy cycle history
model encounter Edge case the answer is
that's that's the best question okay
that's a great question and the answer
is yes what are edge
cases do you guys know what are edge
cases in in this
model who what would be edge cases here
in
history okay it it's called great man
Theory
okay great man
Theory and this is a problem meaning
like okay we
believe we argue that these underlying
historical forces control Humanity right
but now and then you have this great man
come out of nowhere and he changes the
course of human history forever okay the
example is um before we had Homer right
then we had
Dante then we had Plato uh Jesus Julius
Caesar Octavius ptin today okay we can't
account for these people because by
definition they're beyond
history they can step outside of history
and control history that's what great
men are so how does your model account
for that okay
and the answer is you
cannot
so in Foundation okay the solution okay
so there's a solution to
this the solution is to create another
organization okay remember that pych
history it's an AI model it's it's basic
a
computer but as Eric points out you will
always have Ed Edge cases you'll always
have someone appear out of nowhere and
if for for whatever reason he's able to
May manipulate events to control and
direct history in his favor okay so what
you do to solve this problem is you
create another organization okay and in
I think aso's Foundation it's called the
second
Foundation
okay the idea of the second Foundation
is that you there is a computer there is
the AI okay but behind the AI are a team
of specialists
who observe the AI who observe history
and who correct the AI for edge cases
okay does that make sense so if Putin
appears and it's like okay well clearly
I'm not accounting for Putin well then I
change the equations in the AI to
account for Putin okay so this team of
experts sign second foundation will
correct the
AI right now what's interesting about SE
second Foundation is
that these people are
telepaths okay telepaths meaning that
they can read your mind not only can
they read your mind but they can control
your mind okay
so and and that's another really
interesting about psycho history like
okay there's a promise that we can
predict the future but there's also the
promise that within our minds there are
some special abilities that we might
have the potential for but we never ever
fully attempted to achieve
okay does that make sense and is it
possible in the future that telepaths
will rise I think yes and the answer is
that you can make the argument
that these edge cases that Eric refers
to these Great Men of the great men of
history they're actually
telepaths okay does it make sense
they're actually t so someone like Putin
why is Putin able to do what he does and
you you can make the argument like he he
h he has almost some telepathic
abilities okay he can read other
people's minds he can control other
people's minds how else can you explain
that someone who does not come from a
special background right he's not of the
Russian Elite but he's able to
amass so much power
all by himself in only a few decades so
that today he's basically the Emperor of
Russia and all
Russia heeds his command Russia just
moves the way that he wants it to move
okay so you can make the argument that
Putin is almost a
telepath and is it possible that in the
future we'll have more
telepaths and we can over
time harness the power of these
telepaths to create the second
foundation and to control psycho history
possibly
right okay because like how else we
explain Great Men okay um you look at
someone like Homer and Dante right the
only explanation that you can have for
hom and Dante
is they were they had God giving gifts
okay or maybe God was speaking to them
or maybe they were just speaking for God
right that's the only explanation that
you can have for Homer and and Dante
because they so clearly stepped out of
history and directed history does that
make
sense
okay but thanks for the question Eric
okay so edge cases are great men who
appear now and then and you cannot ever
predict these people
okay any
questions
okay
just yeah yes yes
elen oh that's a great question okay um
okay how do you
model love learn and create okay and the
answer is that there has to be a certain
amount of Aon e omy or
agency in the lives of people does that
make sense what we call freedom and
liberty because if you have freedom and
liberty then you're able to do what you
want and what you want to do is
love um create and and grow okay does
that make sense so you need to
model um agency and freedom into the
structure okay the second thing is um
social
interaction okay in other words the more
we're able to interact with each
other the more we're willing to love
create and grow because these Powers
come from others right you can't love
yourself you have to love someone else
you can't create by yourself you have to
create in a group okay you can't learn
by yourself you have to learn you have
to learn from others okay so you also
have to model in um as much group
interaction as
possible okay and the last thing is you
also have to model in the idea of
compassion okay so the idea here is
that
um if I all put you on an island
together okay and you must
survive well you will become
compassionate with each other because
that's the only way to survive right but
if I put you guys into a bank and I say
to you that if you make a million
dollars and I give I give you $2 million
who whoever makes the most money I will
give a Ferrari to you guess what guys
you you you all hate each other you will
all want to kill each other okay you
understand so this model also has to
factor compassion how compassionate is
the
society okay because if you have
compassion then people are willing to
work together if people are willing to
work together then people have the
greater capacity to love create and grow
okay does that make
sense actually guys we have all these
theories it's just like no one's turning
this into a meical model okay for
society any more
questions yeah
um yeah so uh Eric asked the question is
it POS possible to completely understand
human behavior and
motivation and um there are two
different ways of looking at looking at
the issue okay the first way is to use a
social science approach okay so you look
at economics psychology anthropology
sociology right what what are they
trying to do they're trying
to um figure out mathematic Ally what
drives us okay do you understand but
there's another approach it's called the
literature approach which is
that we can actually
quantify or
explain human
behavior okay but they are there are
truths that can be expressed in
literature okay does that make sense so
think
about the very first book we read the
ilad right
where Achilles has killed Hector and PR
Prime wants a body back so Prime sneaks
into Achilles tent and kisses his hand
right that moment you can never
mathematically express it you can only
write about it but think about how much
truth and power is in that one
scene okay does does does does that make
sense um Eric okay so I so again I think
like someone like Homer and
Dante like their mission is
to express to us in the most beautiful
way the human truths okay like what
drives us and Donnie is very explicit he
says that what drives us is love and the
willingness to imagine okay that's who
we are if we love we'll be more human if
we imagine we'll be more human okay and
and that's really the argument I make as
well all right and that has to be
the underlying truth of whatever AI
model that you model you create
okay all right any more
questions
yeah um okay so Seline asked great
question okay well if it says that we
want to love create and grow then why do
we end up destroying ourselves and the
answer is that love and
hate are a are one force you understand
if I can't love you I'm gonna hate you
you understand okay guess what guys
creation and
destruction is one force as well if I
can't create then I want to destroy
why because my need for creation can't
be satisfied does that make sense so a
society that nurtures are willing to
love and create and grow like the Greeks
will flourish okay but eventually you
reach a point where the elite have a
mass power they've centralized and
consolidate power and so they
want to turn everyone else into
basically a slave when you're a slave
you can't love you can't create you
can't learn you can't grow therefore you
Rebel and you destroy the society okay
does that make sense
okay but again the fundamental human
need are these three things but within
each of these things is another
force and if love can't express itself
then hate will Express itself does does
that make sense
okay all right any more
questions
yeah so Sally asked a great question
which is like who who would control this
AI um and how can we ensure that this AI
is not
exploited uh by the elite in order to
justify their corrupt corruption and
cruelty okay um and the answer has to be
um really the second Foundation okay
basically a group of Scholars academics
experts who dedicate themselves to this
AI okay and this AI the the other thing
is that it has to be open and
transparent that's why it's so hard to
build right it has to be open it has to
be open and
transparent okay if it's open and
transparent then everyone has to agree
that this AI is going to be used for
good okay meaning that what this AI does
is you can ask a different
questions and it will give you different
scenarios and we can all agree on which
we want and therefore we can agree on
what action to take Okay so this AI has
to be part of a democratic system where
everyone is involved otherwise as s
points out it can only be abused okay
can only be used to
oppress
others okay but the point of this AI is
that um it gives us a platform
as humans to agree on certain actions
that we must stick
together okay does that make sense so
for example we can all agree that
climate change is bad we can all agree
that war is bad right but this AI will
actually give us Solutions the to these
problems because this AI can map out the
future for us and AI will say well
listen
if um the United States intervenes in
Ukraine then this will happen right
United States attacks Iran then this
will happen and that becomes a very
powerful argument for correct and proper
behavior okay does does that make sense
all right but again um guys this is just
conjecture okay and I I've already said
this it's going to take at least 50 to
100 years to build this Ai and you will
be up against tremendous opposition
right
historians ar aren ar going to like this
the elite aren't going to like
this
right but at the same time we have to
remember like guess
what homer I'm pretty sure if Homer were
uh living in a centralized Society the
elite would be opposed to him okay
because he was making fun of very uh
famous Greeks like Achilles and law and
EG man on right who was making fun of
these guys well guess what when Homer
was writing Society had collapsed right
when Dante was writing Society had
collapsed so if it is
true if my predictions are correct and
Society is approaching collapse then
there should be a lot of space and
leeway and flexibility to create this AI
okay okay any more questions
yeah uh that's a great question uh so if
the won different people different
nations want different outcomes and the
answer is yeah like if you um are alive
today if you're America you want America
to be the Hedge ofon if you're Putin you
want Russia to be the Hedon if you're
China you want China to be the Hedge
ofon right you want different outcomes
so my argument is that um the structure
of society today is not sustainable
everything's going to collapse and we
are going in transition from a
population about 8 billion people to a
population of 1 billion people and when
you have 1 billion people and like
there's no place to grow
crops and uh pollution is everywhere and
war is everywhere guess what
happens humans are united in their goals
which is basically how do we create a
better civilization okay does it make
sense when off has collapsed everyone's
like how do we recreate civilization
that's the goal but in a more
Progressive more
democratic and more prosperous
way okay that's what I'm betting on but
I don't know okay and again um if
everyone's fighting over the AI this AI
cannot be created okay because different
people will want to this AI to be biased
in a different way this AI can only work
if it if it steps steps outside of
history and steps outside of human
interest okay if it's speaking for all
Humanity rather than one nation or one
group of
people okay any more
questions is this clear to you guys all
right so um all right so this is the
very end and I'll spend like five more
minutes to talk
about um this year okay so um this is
the very first time I've taught both
courses okay in the in the first
semester we read the great
books
and um I was blown away by how much you
guys enjoyed the great books and how how
much you benefit from reading the uh
great books okay and quite honestly I
don't think anyone has tried this
before um I know there are great books
courses in
University but not at the pace that we
um had and certainly not at at the level
of difficulty that we had okay so so you
guys should be proud of yourself because
the great books courses was very hard
and um you enjoyed it um even today most
of you really like the ilad right you
guys still remember the Iliad and think
very highly of okay um so so so that's
very impressive so thank you this
semester is also new course uh where we
looked at
geopolitics and um I'm I I'm also very
impressed by how much you've grown as
well in this course uh the way you guys
think it's much more logical much more
antical you guys are asking great
questions okay so um thank you again
because you don't have to work hard in
this course but you chose to work hard
and this is going to carry you very far
um in life okay so um the course
is um has come to an end and I will
share with
you um um why I teach this course okay
because some as some of you know I do
have a very prestigious education
background as well as a care career
background okay
and I could have been what a lawyer I
think a lawyer a rich lawyer a professor
okay but instead I'm teaching High
School in China right why why am I doing
this it's because
um I have three kids okay I have three
three young
kids uh my eldest is six my youngest is
only about eight months okay and as a
father you have to believe in a better
world but not only do you have to
believe in a better world you have to
imine you to fight for it
because um you have to leave behind a
legacy for your children okay so why
teach this course is to bring you a
message of Hope okay like through your
own imagination through your own hard
work you can create a better world you
don't have to sit back and just let the
world happen you don't have to wait for
the future you can make it happen and if
you really work hard at it you can make
the world a better place and I think
like this year has proven to me that I
can make the world a better place if I
work hard because I've seen the growth
in all of you okay so I hope we can stay
in touch I hope that um you will tell me
how you progress because I'm very
confident that all of you will do very
well in University and in life and maybe
some
point we can share this dream of psycho
history you know I know it sounds very
complicated it's very
abstract but to make this work you need
a lot of people working together okay
it's something that's going to happen
tomorrow but it's something that we
might come back to later on in our
lives okay so that's it thank you and
and uh we'll stay in touch okay